it's great to welcome to the program
today Tyler Cowen who is professor of
economics at George Mason University and
also author of the book the complacent
class the self-defeating quest for the
American Dream it's so great to talk to
you I just finished the book yesterday
in fact and it really approaches much of
what is going on in American economics
and culture from a number of different
angles and I think maybe a good place to
start is when you talk about complacency
what are we talking about and how can we
see this complacency in Americans our
society has become less dynamic the
American frontier is gone real wages are
rising at slower rates the rate at which
Americans move across state lines to
find say a new job it's much lower than
it used to be we obsess over the safety
of our kids and we medicate ourselves
much much more we've become a society
obsessed with stasis and safety and is
that a result of something in particular
that's going on in the United States or
is it something that we could point to
in other countries as they achieve a
certain level of you know call it wealth
call it stability whatever the case may
be is that sort of a natural process
that happens in countries it's a natural
process you see very much the same in
most of Western Europe also in Japan but
I do think there are some special
factors to the United States this is the
society where the Internet has advanced
the most and a lot of what the Internet
does is it makes it very easy for us to
stay at home so we post on social media
instead of protesting Amazon delivers
whatever we want we consider on our
sofas and watch Netflix and all this
contributes to today being a kind of age
of complacency can we see this reflected
in terms of innovation small businesses
are there particular industries where
this is particularly noticeable right
now well most of the American economy
so the rate of business startups has
been declining since the 1980s
contrary to what you often hear there
are fewer unicorns than before measured
indices of market
our or monopoly power those are higher
figures for investment or sluggish
figures for productivity growth are
definitely down so our tech sector in
some ways is very dynamic but most of
our economy still is not tech it's
fairly static retailer services and you
see this reflected in real wages which
for most American families on average
have not been growing since 1999 there's
one interesting factor you discuss in
the book which is that segregation by
income has increased in most parts of
the United States you see wealthier
people tending to live together more
poorer people tending to live together
more is that a factor that in your mind
increases complacency or one that
actually might by virtue of inequality
make people maybe more upset with the
status quo and more likely to activate
in some way so far it's made complacency
worse so if you look at our cities a lot
of them are gentrifying so you have more
people who are say yuppies or educated
professionals living together
this makes mobility harder it's harder
for other people to break into those
cities and use that as an economic
ladder upwards I think in the longer run
this may cause the kind of social
explosion but for now if you live in one
of those cities things seem pretty great
and pretty calm and crime rates often
are falling but it's actually a kind of
symbol of our longer-run decay that
poorer people are clustered together
living somewhere else and we simply
don't see them so much what do you see
is the or do you see or through what
mechanism might that trend eventually
sort of implode as you sort of
suggesting and create fallout in some
sense would it be an economic recession
would it be further inequality what type
of factor might cause that sequence to
start I think further declines in
mobility so the older American notion
that it will you could move to a big
city and work your way up and in the
meantime pay a reasonable rent that's
pretty much dead today and again in the
short run that feels like maybe
fortunate but something we can live with
but I think if you have two or three
generations in a row for upward mobility
keeps on falling there is eventually
some kind of point of an explosion or an
implosion I don't quite feel we're there
yet but there's much more credentialism
and American society many more jobs need
licenses or you might need a master's
degree and all of these over all their
monthly bad for poorer people they're
bad for social and economic mobility you
talk in the book and you just mentioned
observe Geographic mobility the idea of
moving maybe from a rural area to a city
for a job you also talked in the book
quite a bit towards the beginning I
believe it is about how it has become
less and less common for feet for people
in the u.s. to move long distances for
jobs that's a really interesting part of
the book to me because in many other
parts of the world like for example I'm
from Argentina and a lot of my family
there will talk to me about how it seems
like in the u.s. so many people live on
the other side of the country than where
they grew up or where their parents live
or whatever the case may be it's
sometimes seen as sort of a less nice
thing from the point of view of a
cohesive family unit
but you point to the decreased mobility
in terms of moving for jobs is actually
a negative indicator of where things are
going can you talk about that a little
bit is the rate at which Americans move
across state lines is down about 50
percent compared to its post to our
average think this is a very bad symptom
it's basically suggesting there are not
many parts of the country that are
growing very dynamically there's Silicon
Valley but most people's don't have the
skills to work there where you can't
afford the rent and otherwise like why
bother moving from Columbus Ohio to
Denver or vice versa
you see a lot of people they move ones
they figure out where they want to live
they stay there again in the short run
that's very comfortable but in the
longer run it essentially means that our
labor markets are slower to adjust our
economy is less dynamic we've given up
this earlier American frontier mentality
and it's again contributing to stasis
and complacency is it risk aversion that
you would characterize as one of these
sort of rye
using contributors to this from a from
an individual perspective I know we've
talked about and you talked about in the
book a lot of the sort of country or
maybe macro level factors that have
contributed from but from the point of
view of the individual how does risk
aversion play into this a lot of it's
risk aversion like why pick up and move
to a new area when you're not sure
what's there but I think a lot of it is
just a smoothing out across regions a
lot of America is more the same than it
used to be Amazon will deliver anywhere
you want retail malls in different parts
of the country they feel the same you
can be a dentist in many parts of the
country so the overall picture is simply
one where the reasons to move have gone
down and the desire has gone down to you
talk in the book about other sort of
technological factors that relate to
better matching and by matching we mean
that it's very easy to go directly in
the romantic world for example to dating
people that you've already matched with
to a greater degree than someone you
might randomly encounter on public
transit you are increasingly able to in
the work world have better matching that
will keep you in comfortable situations
social media has played a big role in
this you've got Spotify and Pandora
you might never even have to hear a song
you don't like just that in all areas
there's this sort of bubble of comfort
that has developed how is that something
that takes away ones maybe incentive or
drive to do something that is that is
more risky in some way well it does have
a big upside especially for people who
match well but think about couples in
marriage there are many more power
couples than ever before and of course a
lot of these families are happy we
shouldn't begrudge that but the
longer-run impact of this on inequality
and mobility I think will be significant
you'll have much larger bequests you'll
have both the husband and the wife or
the you know the two men or the two
women in the same sex marriage those
having very high incomes and
contributing those financial resources
to the children so it's really great for
those at the top and those at the bottom
who are trying to climb up we'll find
there
having a harder time we've been speaking
about the book the complacent class the
self-defeating quest for the American
dream with the book's author Tyler Cowen
we'll pause there and continue our
conversation with him on tomorrow's
program we're continuing our
conversation with Tyler Cowen who's
professor of economics at George Mason
University also author of the book the
complacent class the self-defeating
quest for the American dream
so in the first part of the interview we
talked about some of the characteristics
that allow us to see this complacency
that you described in the book we also
talked a little bit about what has
caused it I want to focus now on the
possible impacts and consequences and at
the end of the book you talk about
national security you talk about a
number of other factors that you believe
over the long term will be affected by
the complacency that you've identified
let's start there over the next 10 20 50
years
how will the United States be impacted
by this growing complacency that you've
described well let's look at our
government what we find when you examine
the federal budget is that each year
more and more of it is taken up by
expenditures that are locked in Social
Security or Medicare or Medicaid now I'm
not at all saying we shouldn't have
these programs but we're taking less and
less of tax revenue and devoting it
toward research and development toward
discretionary spending toward
infrastructure we're taking fewer
chances we're spending more and more of
our money on just protecting the
positions people already have and
insulating them from risk this is very
different from what we did say in the
1960s and I feel it's a big mistake so
in the longer run what will happen is
our government is losing the ability to
respond flexibly to crises or to come up
with the next moonshot or you know
invent the next big development as it
once did with nuclear power so that to
me is very concerning and is that I mean
I think we can all imagine how that
leads directly into the national
security concerns of a country in the
sort of stasis that you described that's
right in the notion that America might
have to do something where American
soldiers suffer casualties that's become
extremely unpopular we fight wars by
drone and again in any single in
since that fields may be comfortable or
like the right thing to do but I worry
that we're losing our ability to deter
our allies do not trust us much anymore
and our influence and projection of
power in the world I see that is going
down rapidly yet the military thing is
an interesting one because we had we had
layer one of sort of the average
American being removed from what the
military is doing by virtue of not
having not needing a draft here in the
United States you've got an
all-volunteer military so it's very easy
for most Americans never to even think
about what the military is doing now
you've got layer two of that removal
which is the increased use of drones and
distance warfare do you think that that
also is part of this sort of comfort
bubble that you described in the book
very much so and arguably the next
generation of war will be cyber warfare
which is yet another kind of removal and
I feel when it comes to that like as
long as the internet is working today we
don't see a problem but we're recording
the next 9/11 or Pearl Harbor and I
think at some point there will be a
major cyber attack on American assets or
institutions and we're basically not at
all ready for that we just think life is
fine now it can't really happen to us
the big mistake what do you see in
developing countries in terms of factors
that cause this complacency not to be
there is it simply the need for
self-preservation and and staying alive
due to a far reduced standard of living
are there other more intangible factors
I think the whole attitude toward risk
is very different so in the book I give
the example of China yeah now I'm not
saying the US should be like China but
the attitude is well if you don't go out
and take some chances risk will come and
get you so people are very proactive and
very aggressive I think at least at the
margin we should learn something from
that and you see Chinese immigrants when
they come to this country they do very
well and in part it's because they're
carrying that attitude with them I would
say overall immigrants are the least
complete complacent people in American
society right now yeah and in the book
you also talk about I mean not not just
Chinese immigrants but and this actually
relates a lot to stereo
types that we often hear from elected
officials or political pundits or
whoever about lazy immigrants leeching
off of social welfare programs the
evidence doesn't really back up that
caricature does it correct and you know
Latinos and Mexicans mexican-americans
they're the group most likely to move
around the country in search of a new
job far more likely than say native-born
non Latino Americans and that's to their
credit it's very dynamic now do you
think that that's as a result of them
being from particular countries or more
related to their status in the United
States as new immigrants I think the
fact that they came here means they're
risk takers to begin with they're
accustomed to the idea of moving they
don't find it some unthinkable shock
obviously they don't necessarily have
strong ties to the first part of the
United States they've come to settle in
and if someone says hey there's a better
job for you in Chicago I think their
attitude is why not let's try it they
can always go back say to Mexico or
Central America that's a very healthy
attitude when it comes to political
decisions that are made by whoever's in
the White House whoever's in charge in
the House of Representatives or the
Senate are the differences between
Democrats and Republicans in terms of
how they will impact this broader stasis
and complacency even noticeable or is
this an area in which all of our elected
officials are quite similar in terms of
whether they would even change the
status quo you described I think in a
funny way they're quite similar so
anyone who watches politics you see at
the rhetorical level there has not been
so much polarization for a long time
what the Trump people say the Clinton
people say it all sounds so horrible
they attack each other but when you get
right down to what's likely to happen
with the budget say the failure of the
Republicans to roll back Obamacare
whether you agree with that or not I
think we see we're living in a time of
stasis where not many things change and
on fundamentals there's a lot more
agreement across the two parties we're
actually just not really going to do
very much the visions of Trump make
America great again very backward
looking calorie Clinton was backward
looking to the 90s into the Obama
administration a big contrast with say
JFK who talked all about the new
frontier what's an example of the type
of policy that a president could
actually possibly propose and effect
that would change the direction that you
identify in the book more money for
research and development with our
infrastructure to get that moving again
and I don't just mean repairing roads
and tunnels so that's fine but to do
something like help implement the smart
grid or introduce more online education
we need to make it much easier for poor
people to move into cities so deregulate
building in those cities to some extent
there's a lot we could do I think the
key point is neither party seems that
interested in actually doing it's a fair
amount of talk that very little action
on either side yeah that may be I mean
at the same time what you're talking
about
it there's no guarantee that we would
see it from a Republican or a Democrat
but it certainly sounds to me like
something at least more like the
language you'd hear from Democrats don't
you think yes but keep in mind Democrats
also want to expand a lot of other parts
of the budget entitlement spending and
that will tend to crowd out the
possibility of these programs so you
know you can debate you know which party
you prefer or social issues but I think
in the longer run it's actually going to
look fairly similar once you get past
all the rhetoric have you given any
thought to the impact of such
significant defense spending on the way
we more generally allocate resources and
the stasis and complacency that you
described partially from the idea that
we could maybe increase complacency by
knowing that we've got this massive
military industrial complex and that so
much money is tied up in bombs and
defense and so on and so forth what's
your sense about that I think people
feel quite safe they feel in a sense too
safe they're neglecting perhaps
cyberattack but what will happen is as
we continue to age it will cost more and
more money to sustain people in in their
older years which I'm all for doing but
it will mean a lot of pressure on the
defense budget
a lot of our capabilities infrastructure
you see that eroding already it's been
the case for some time
our Navy getting weaker in relative
terms and that's the likely trend it's
just kind of upkeep and innovation in a
lot of areas other than maintaining the
elderly we see those already going down
you talk about China in the book as you
described and China's circumstances are
quite different than those of the United
States have you identified any country
that is more at the level of development
or wealth that is the United States but
that has policies that you would find to
be better policies for fighting spaces
and complacency I think both Canada and
Australia have somewhat better policies
than we do those were countries that
were once once bluer than America now
they're each slightly better off and
they're better governed so we could
learn some things from them I would
start with those two places but for the
most part complacency has come to most
other wealthy countries whatwhat about
the role of healthcare I mean I know
it's interesting you mentioned Canada
and Australia both of which were
recently ranked in a study of twelve
wealthier nations more developed nations
as having some of the better health care
systems in terms of their effectiveness
they do not have the sort of employer
connected for-profit health care systems
of the United States does that play a
role here that plays a role with respect
to America I think it's one of these you
can't get there from here stories so if
we had better policy say in 1972 you
could imagine American healthcare right
now being much cheaper but given how
much we pay to think that will cut those
payments to doctors and medical devices
and hospitals it's very hard for me to
see that happening so I think we're
stuck in this box where for us truly
universal coverage would be very costly
people demand it they're not really sure
how to get it people now want more
single-payer but in terms of actually
footing the bill I don't think we're
close to any kind of consensus no no
consensus but have you seen some of the
analyses like for example by Gerald
Friedman at the University of
Massachusetts on sort of debunking or
attempting to debunk the idea that we
can't afford that I don't think we can
afford it on
lest the American public would raise its
collective hands and say well I'm
willing to accept a 5% say that tax
everything I spend whether or not they
should do that you can debate but I
don't see any willingness at all to you
know face up to those costs and say okay
let's do it
it's all thought of in terms of a free
lunch like somehow if we have
single-payer these costs will magically
fall but Medicare is a kind of
single-payer for the elderly that's
still a pretty expensive system much
more than what Canada or Australia spend
yet ensuring its elderly that's true a
very very interesting conversation and I
highly recommend the book which is of
course the complacent class the
self-defeating quest for the American
Dream economics professor Tyler Cowen is
the book's author thanks so much for
talking to us about this my pleasure
thank you